chaos and violence as Zimbabwe police
clashed with opposition supporters
firing tear gas and water cannons to
disperse the protesters earlier on
Friday demonstrators took to the streets
of Harare after their plans for
large-scale marches were banned by
police late on Thursday night they're
angry at the government blaming them for
the country's dire economic situation if
we demonstrate peacefully we won't
change what we are tired of promises
promises promises we are tired enough is
enough we have the power that is my hope
to say this decision bring it was
supposed to be the first in a series of
protests across the country organized by
the main opposition party movement for
Democratic Change after Zimbabwe's High
Court rejected their challenge to the
ban opposition leaders vowed to continue
fighting we are not backing down we are
going forward the people of Zimbabwe
attacked they are fed up they want to
end this long suffering so while
proceeding with the matches for
everything
as police launched the crackdown the
ruling party's an issued a warning to
demonstrators with almost a third of the
country's population in need of aid
demonstrators are set to keep up their
calls for change however police attempt
to stop them
my first guest today is the youth chair
for the Movement for Democratic Change
or MDC or basically is in Harare welcome
to 2dw Africa mr. sertori what was the
planned purpose for today's protests
okay today we had a planned protest
which was going to be peaceful what
you're trying to advocate for is to
ensure that the country code Zimbabwe
goes back to a sanity we are facing a
lot of challenges at the whip of
Zimbabwe there's a lot of corruption
unemployment the pip of Zimbabwe we are
also facing high levels of human rights
violations among other issues so we are
saying it's high time at the people of
Zimbabwe we need to exercise our
concessional rights as enshrined under
section 59 of the Zimbabwean
Constitution whereby everyone is the
right to demonstrate and petition this
is what exactly we planned for
unfortunately we witnessed the nature in
which the government is allergic to the
constitutionalism because they have
banned the Proteas that was going to be
peaceful so what is followed today it
was in EA a scenario whereby people are
being detained in the city of Ferrari
for simply walking in the streets which
is not an act of criminality or
illegality okay obey hang on one second
I'd like for us to listen to a
representative from the ruling party
speaking and then I want to get your
reaction to that let's listen to the
representative
to demonstration to anarchy we'll be
there waiting for them obey is it your
party's mission to have the zanu-pf
government led by MSM 9gag wa Elstad
it's quite unfortunate that we have some
people individuals who live in a country
called Zimbabwe which is clearly
stipulates that everyone is a right to
diversity and is to find people again is
that a constitutional right it only
confirms that you are under a government
that is disrespectful to the
Constitution and these are some of the
reasons why we are standing up as the
people of Zimbabwe to say enough is
enough we cannot continue to hear the
government that does not respect the
people's will a government that does not
respect the provisions of the
Constitution it's quite unfortunate
that what we have witnessed today is a
product of violence and the violent is
account which is a god obey my question
to you was is it your party's mission to
have this government outside and I I
think I heard you confirm that it brings
me to my next question there have been
some voices in Zimbabwe critical of the
MDC leadership in particular for letting
people to go to the streets and we saw
what happened today people are assaulted
and the question is the leadership
themselves are not on the ground with
the people does your party bears some of
the responsibility for those people
who've been injured today the people had
walked in the city of Zimbabwe based on
the acquisition of provisions it is
unfortunate that a judgment was made
right on time when people were already
in town so it's quite unfortunate that
it was coincidental people had walked in
town because they were setting that the
protest is going on has provided for the
supervisor supreme love supreme law of
the land it's unfortunate that some
ultra vires laws have been a I have been
taken from the archives to ensure that
the table the people's protect so what
is happen today unfortunately it's also
not fair to say the leadership was not
there
sorry I must cut you off they obey
because I do want to get this in perhaps
you can continue your answer and include
this as well
the MDC calling for future
demonstrations are no more had been
planned for those go ahead of course
they'll go ahead because no one is above
the law and the supreme law of this land
allows people to demonstrate and we are
going to be doing that in a peaceful
manner
as a party our couch is very peaceful
it's unfortunate that you are dealing
with a government that is violent this
is why you saw people being beaten for
no apparent reason when people got into
the streets today
they were very peaceful and somewhere
Britain just for sitting down in the
road that is quite unfortunate so we are
not going to be deterred by the actions
of today we are going to follow and
pursue the same democratic and
concessional cause starting from Monday
all been a blow I choose the urban wear
when is diminishing and testamentary
this is just the first phase of a series
of actions that we are going to be
pursuing as a party to ensure that we
usher in a People's Government that is
respectful to the people of Zimbabwe a
base it solely from the Movement for
Democratic Change or MDC thank you